So Donald Trump's casual musings about the
potential to declare martial law reportedly
have the military on red alert, but not on red
alert to participate in enforcing the martial law.
In fact, it's quite the opposite. The military
is not on red alert, preparing to enforce martial
law, which is a suspension of civil law in lieu
of military justice becoming the law of the land.
The military is on red alert not because
they want to be prepared to help Trump.
They want to be prepared in case protesters go
so crazy if Trump tries to install martial law
that the military might be required to help
quell violence and restore order. Multiple
officers who spoke to Newsweek, of course, on
the condition of anonymity, agree that there's no
chance whatsoever that the military would actually
try to help Donald Trump overturn the results or
enforce the martial law that Trump is supposedly
using and wondering about. But with the military
officers are worried about, is that by trying
to push martial law, if Trump were to do it,
that the military could end up getting sucked
into having to clean up the mess that Donald Trump
might make. And the thought is that Donald
Trump could inadvertently or deliberately
rally so-called private militias and pro Trump
paramilitary types, and the military could
end up being needed to help protect from those
groups. Now, the consensus is that there is no
group or contingent or cabal of military officers
that would actually go with Donald Trump's idea.
But the military could end up needing to come
to the defense of the people depending on what
happens. And notably, the contingency
planning is happening completely out
of sight of the White House and the known
Trump loyalists at the Pentagon, because
the military recognizes that if you involve the
White House or Trump loyalists in the Pentagon
in and let them know that you're planning in this
way, they may actually try to interfere with what
you're doing or even notify Donald Trump. And
along those lines, the other crazy aspect of this
is that top military brass understand that
if they publicly said we would never support
any attempt at martial law because
Trump thinks he really won when he lost,
they recognize that if they went public with their
names, it could make Trump go absolutely crazy
and make him more likely to try this stuff. So the
reporting is that the military officer community
is just kind of laying low contingency planning
out of sight, but not attaching their names to any
specific public rebukes of Donald Trump's martial
law musings. And to be frank, I understand that.
And the question comes up of whether Donald
Trump, absent support from the military,
would try to pull in Blackwater type mercenary
groups or others, which would be just a new
level of insanity. And hopefully it will never
come to that. Donald Trump just went to Florida
for the holiday. And there's the idea that Trump
may never even come back to Washington, D.C.,
like you may just stay in Florida. This will all
fade away and be nothing or not. We don't know.
I've actually already left the country. I've not
even been in the U.S. for a bit. I'm not going
to be back until after the inauguration. The
show will look the same. I've been mentioning,
you know, multiple studios lately. Nothing will
change when we get back from New Year's break.
But I'm beating the rush and I'm just going
to be elsewhere for the next period of time
y chance it you know that. That's my approach. And
then just one last thing. This is also part of why
the Electoral College should really be gotten rid
of. Biden won by about eight million votes, but
about 100000 votes in a few swing states were
the margin that provided the electoral victory.
The electoral victory seems much more plausibly
overturning when it comes down to 100000 votes
in a handful of states, whereas how do you
even plausibly claim to try to circumvent an
eight million vote loss? Just another signal about
the the importance of continuing to fight to get
rid of the Electoral College. And that's even a
separate issue than the Electoral College helps
Republican president. Yes, it does. But regardless
of that, there are other reasons to get rid of it.